and here the nominees for Best Animated  Feature Film the Croods Chris Sanders  Kirk DeMicco and Christine Belson  Despicable Me 2 chris renaud pierre  coffin and Chris Miller danji Ernest and  Celestine Benjamin Renner and Didier  Bruner  frozen chris buck jennifer lee and peter  delve FF the wind rises hayao miyazaki  and Toshio Suzuki wanna say I'd like to  try the Oscar goes to  oh are you ready  frozen  we're gonna do this together because  we're collaborative but we'll be fast  first we want to thank each and every  person at Walt Disney Animation Studios  our family we are so proud of you for  making the film as magical as it is and  we're bringing this home to you and for  our personal families and dearest  friends thank you so much for supporting  us through this hard work and for really  being our inspiration and finally we'd  like to dedicate this to our guardian  angel that's my son writer buck thank  you